just look at this donald rumsfeld was
brash and abrasive
infamously so his critics say the
combination was the former u.s defense
secretary's undoing
during the worst days of the u.s war in
iraq
rumsfeld's take he was right his critics
were wrong
and they couldn't stand it it's a fact
i'm a survivor rumsfeld was a survivor
of washington politics
he made history as both the youngest and
the oldest secretary of defense
and he did the bidding of four
republican presidents
in 1983 president ronald reagan sent
rumsfeld to baghdad
to try to broker closer ties with saddam
hussein
but two decades later it was defense
secretary rumsfeld
who argued saddam had to go in rejecting
the president's ultimatum
the iraqi regime has chosen war over
peaceful disarmament and a u.s led war
was the way to make that happen
he and other bush administration
officials accused iraq
of helping to plan the september 11th
attacks which it did not
rumsfeld also accused iraq of possessing
weapons of mass destruction
which it did not he was wrong but
rumsfeld refused to say so
we believe the intelligence was correct
it turns out that it was not completely
correct
at first rumsfeld embraced the
neoconservative ideology of exporting
u.s style democracy and nation building
but in his 2013 memoir
rumsfeld changed his tune i did not
think resolving other countries internal
political disputes
paving roads erecting power lines
policing streets
building stock markets and organizing
democratic governmental bodies
were missions for our men and women in
uniform
more important rumsfeldt refused to plan
for the possibility
that iraq could tumble into chaos and
civil war
again he wouldn't apologize there are
known knowns there are things we know we
know
we also know there are known unknowns
that is to say we know there are some
things we do not know
critics said rumsfeld's desire to spend
as little money as possible to fight the
war meant
u.s troops didn't have the protection
they needed from roadside bombs and they
said this exchange between a soldier and
rumsfeld proved he didn't care
now why do we soldiers have to dig
through local landfills
for pieces of scrap metal and compromise
ballistic glass to up armor our vehicles
and why don't we have those resources
readily available to us
you go to war with the army you have not
the harmony you might want
or wish to have around the world
rumsfeld was a symbol of u.s arrogance
the military prison at guantanamo opened
on his watch
we are going to treat them exactly all
right
that's right and the abuhab abuse
scandal exploded while rumsfeld was in
charge
with the u.s war in iraq going badly
rumsfeld resigned at the end of 2006
leaving a legacy that is decidedly
controversial
rosalind jordan al jazeera